because I decided relatively early on
why should I invest somewhere
with five, eight or ten or twelve
percent and then I have
to trust the people who do the
business there,
especially I'll say it with the knowledge
that especially in the start-up area they do
The probability that the whole thing will be
successful is very very low, I
mean we know that everyone is
very, very low, so I was throwing my money out the
window because I was in contractions
, I really didn’t feel like it,
but if so, I said I would go
to their own company with them  I
also play a certain role.
American investors are in the
process of selling shares in their
clubs in the Premier League, um, and
Arab investors are pushing very hard,
for example at Newcastle, they are
now pushing very hard into
the market, everyone has now seen
financial fair play  that was
a toothless tiger
and now we all saw
wi too  e many clubs have simply made
tens of millions of losses
100 million 150 million 200
millionth names of the
clubs everyone can imagine made
huge losses without the
consequences today as a guest on the OMR
podcast after Uli Hoeneß after akivatzke
after Toni Kroos after Christian  Seifert
who is still missing from the German
football legends with whom you can talk about
football and football business
correctly Oliver Kahn the
CEO of Bayern Munich
talked to me about his career his
view of the Bundesliga on the Super
League on German football on the
business
all in all, of course, ask all the questions from Qatar to the
future of Bavaria, let's go and
by the way, if you miss some of the names just mentioned
, here is the YouTube channel, not
all of our podcasts are
broadcast as videos on YouTube, the
others can be found wherever there are
podcasts,
hello
servus I would now from the beginning before  we are
now talking about Bayern and football and the
economy it all started for you in Karlsruhe
and you were born with so much
talent that you knew you would become a
professional footballer back then,
so I think nothing works without talent,
but I don’t really know
great talent where everyone has now said he
will definitely be a Bundesliga
player one day I was more of someone who
was willing
to work a lot to train a lot
because we just enjoyed it
and had fun but I think
others and that was  an important
experience that I had at a young
age, others were always
talented, at least that's what they said,
I often played in the second
teams
when I was young and then realized very quickly if
you want to pack, you have to do
more like them  others and that was
a kind of
apprenticeship right from the start, which later became my philosophy as a
professional  to feel good in the
game i always had to train a lot it
didn't take that long then
you were suddenly the most expensive
goalkeeper transfer in history back then
i think it was like 2.4 million
or something like that from Karlsruhe to Bayern
um in euros but it was back then  Yes,
you still have twice the topic and I can
still remember when I came to
Munich, it was 1994 and it was
also the first time it was
rumored, yes, how can you
pay a goalkeeper’s salary, I think it was
for the first time  More than a million Deutschmarks
that was an unbelievable amount at the time
and then also for
a goalkeeper so the discussion
I still have today I still have it
somewhere um in my ear what of course it was clear
to go to Munich that we did back then
yes somehow that was the greatest thing there
were no alternatives or somehow
England Italy it was tried for you Munich
so they tried everything
for me Karl  to make sruhe palatable
because we have yes it was a
very successful time with great
players yes Michael sternenkopf with
Scholl Oliver Kreuzer Jens Novotny many
many great talents at KSC
but for me it was clear for me
it was always Bayern Munich I was
already as  young guy with the Bayern
flag stood in the KSC fan block, which
can't be so harmless, but
when Bayern played in
Karlsruhe and the club
always had
a great fascination for me,
and as Uli Hoeneß then I eventually fascinated
me  I think it was 93 in the winter of December
called I first thought that the local
radio station that was trying to make fun of me somehow
didn't believe it at all, but
then I found out that it was Uli
Uli hoenes and he then asked me
yes you can imagine
to come to FC Bayern and I should have my
typical evening yes I have to do that
first of all I have to  I had to think about it first
, but it was immediately clear to me
that this is a great opportunity
and one should take advantage of everything
that was already being advised
at the time
not yet the
time when every player already had an
adviser then of course when
the Bayern Munich topic came up my
first adviser, unfortunately deceased
Norbert flippen was my first adviser
who was also adviser to Lothar Matthäus was
exactly my legend of me yes then
simply my interests
and then it went to FC Bayern in 1994 and
then it started slowly so unfortunately it starts
is good then there were some special
moments of happiness where you say
okay that could have gone differently
so probably before that in
Karlsruhe in the early  bayernzeit
have the feeling football are
sometimes so small twists
would decide something would have developed differently
h  everything could have turned out very differently
but then
somehow the wave was so big for you that you
knew it was going now
it is indeed like that, there are many people
behind you, you always stand
there and talk about success and
personal success and  blabla and
still there are so many little
moments when you
just need that little bit of luck in life for me it
was also my first coach I am
Schäfer and who had to
decide between Stefan
Wimmer that was my
competitor at the time that was  the son of the
long-time
goalkeeper legend Rudi Wimmer and with the
status I was such a competitor and like
the shepherds I had to make a decision at some point
yes which of the
two should I take to the pros
and that was a moment like
that then it happened  decided for me
these are such small moments in which
your career could of course have taken one or the
other turn yes then
my first covenant  Esliga games
were anything but
particularly great, I think
I lost all the first three players, so
it was actually said,
well, you can forget
the boat, he might become a
good amateur goalkeeper, yes, um, but the
Bundesliga is rather difficult and then there was
a game  in the Wildpark Stadium back then
against VfL Bochum
and the native aubert Alexander famila
made two mistakes in the first half, I think
, which then led to
goals and Winnie then yells at me
after the half-time whistle, yes, you can
come in and leave
the substitutes’ bench, startled, okay  said good
then I'll come in now I
wrote then had to
hold a single ball in the second half but
that was decisive yes we
then made three to two from zero to
two in the Wildpark Stadium and that
was the starting moment for me ever
since  I was consistently number
one at KSC and then later at
Bayern Munich as well  say of
course there are always these moments
in such a career and I
think that's what always makes you
a little bit humbled and always
makes me a little bit humbled when
you talk about the topic of success and
at Bayern there was  anyway or
was it
completely against me at first uh when I came in
1994 after a few months
coach was Giovanni Trapattoni and
after a few months I ruptured the
cruciate ligament, that means the whole
knee was ruptured meniscus was ruptured
cruciate ligament was ruptured and  my
career was already hanging by a thread
and things weren't going well either. I was
with Bayern Munich 6. You
have to imagine that from
today's perspective and yes
, I had to work on it again. I
can fight up there  out of the
injury and what I did then
, thank God, also succeeded, so it
was a pretty
bumpy state in Bavaria with many
Sc  difficulties but yes, I think those
are important moments and in this
business of
football as a professional,
nothing is given for free and it's just about getting
through the difficult moments and also learning something from them
for yourself and them bit by bit
Little bit then continue to fight and your
sporting career children most
what won almost everything that
you can win than than as more active
what moments are for you a two
absolute that that was always
remembered that will remain the highlights
is then champions league or
what was it, yes, you always think it's
always only the positive moments that
stick with you after a career
, but what you as a player found
extremely negative, such
as the Champions League
defeat in '99, where we lost in two out of three
minutes  after paying the Champions
United as a gift, so to speak,
or the lost World Cup final for me in
2002 are yes  negative experiences
Champions League then
also win 2000 2001 of
course a great moment in the
penalty shoot-out
FC Valencia went back then what do I want to
say they are all highly emotional
moments and that's what
sport is about, these enormous emotions that you
experience when you win but also when you
lose  you don't experience it
anywhere else I
experienced it later in business too, yes, which I
enjoyed a lot, many
entrepreneurial things, but the
emotions you experienced there at
a Champions League final before
I know how many millions of people World Cup
Standing in front of billions of spectators in
the final is so special
and of course it's such an
adrenaline-filled moment that just
doesn't exist anymore when your career is over
, but let's tell a moment
that that's the Champions League, of
course the Champions League  Final back then
we had yes I just said
99 so really brut  The best way was to lose
the Champions League final and
then we fought our way
through it for two years or a great team fought through it for two years
again and then we were in the final then
Valencia in Milan and then there
was still a lot of drama on
penalties and then we had that
Thank God I won that was of course a
moment of happiness that was why this moment was so nice because FC Bayern has been
more than 25 years old I think this title
belongs to this Champions League title and
yes he failed terribly again and
again in the finals I still have a final
against him  Remembering FC Porto yes
that is a famous goal and
so FC Bayern
just didn't have any luck in the finals again and again and
that's why it was an unbelievable moment of happiness for the club for everyone
for the fans and of course for the
players
when finally this me
was able to save that last penalty, which
I didn't even know that was the one that would
decide  It's okay, I was
traveling in such a tunnel-like way, so in such a
tunnel I said, by the way, I have to
stop every ball that's
shot at my goal and you can see
it on TV if
you watch it again, yes I will stop then
Pellegrino's last penalty
and then look very briefly in the middle, that
's the way it was decisive now
and then I see our boys how they all start
running and then I knew that
must have been decisive
yes that was of course fantastic
last
football fan question before  we come to other
things who were the one two
most outstanding players with
whom you played
yes at FC Bayern you always have the
opportunity to play with great with
great players whether it was
Lothar Matthäus whether it was giovanne Elba
whether it was whether it was
Stefan Effenberg whether it  bit
was so many great guys would you
just yes because they are important
players that Jens was he speaks on today
m  always so from the mentality monster very
amazon concept and he was important he was
he
yes he was a feiter he was a fighter
he was punctuator important
important player so
great none with your remember that
i come in 1994 am french then a
bit crazier but also
great
great guy so many many great
so no one really sticks out for you
what the guy was just
overly talented or overly talented or something
but I would you I would I would
do a lot wrong and right now
but FC Bayern  many of them I would say have
great dispositions you
also interrupted your academic career because of the Bavarians
you already
totally started studying back in the
Karlsruhe period so I read distance learning business administration
yes at the
Fernuniversität Hagen at the time and yes that
was always important to me  but it was
also a matter of bringing up the sun and my
parents have given me relatively
given early the career can be
over quickly because my father had to
experience the experience that you were also a very good
footballer unfortunately had your
injury and he didn’t
fully recover and
I think that was just a lesson that’s
why it’s very important to me  to give again and
again hey you also have to
do something on the side that was one thing
the other for me it was often too
one-dimensional and to have a distraction for my head
or
to challenge my head in a different way
that was important to me and  that's good too
that's true the story that
you asked Bayern
for quiet on the bus as a player and
read Manager Magazin so in
peace I haven't asked for quiet
now yes but May has
stopped  everyone did their things in the
front they played cards, back then they still
played Schafkopf and the others listened to
music, I watched films  Yes
, I also did it in between, but I was
n’t already interested in the subject at the time
for entrepreneurs for
business for management and then I
read all these magazines that’s
true and then after my career
everything ended perfectly, so to speak, that
I think he said goodbye
somehow found it to be a very good fit, but didn't try a
comeback or not very soon,
but you have the feeling that
somehow it ran out so smoothly
then it was clear to you now
I'm going in this management direction
or founder direction or how was
it then  Consideration that's a
good point, so the end of
my career was very important to me and that it will
clearly take place and not like that, yes
, we'll do another year here, another year there
and then we'll go another
two years, I don't know where,
but two  Years earlier in 2006 because the
World Cup in Germany and
then after the playground I played 3 against 4 against
Portugal  As I said, that was my
national team career, which is
now over and I'll be playing
for Bayern Munich for two more years and
then Bayern Munich will be over, that
means it was very clear to me, yes, and
it also helped
the club  Bayern could plan here
Bayern knew exactly what my
plans were
and that's after that when I played
my farewell game here
then I go into the entrepreneurial
world that was somewhere clear to
me that wasn't always fascinated
but I knew  not yet exactly
how, what and and with whom because at
first I didn't do anything at all
then stopped in 2008 and didn't do anything at all
said woah that'll definitely be great
nothing to do because until
then life was completely clocked
I always had a  wonderful example
if you were with the national team
there was always in this
famous DIN A4 note that was
always  Pushed down through the door in the
hotel room, it said exactly
how the next day would be like, 10 a.m.
breakfast 12 p.m. meeting 3 p.m. training
and there was that every day at the
World Cup for six weeks
what that was wonderful like that it
can’t be a note anymore  came through the door
but it was a bit was a
bit difficult to
get used to the fact that my life now we are
determined by someone yes that's
not so easy when you get out of this
football bubble and then
be completely different again  Things
do but yes I first
traveled a lot then vacation more golf and
after nine months I
thought boys that's great but it's getting a
bit boring
and then I just started
studying NBA again because
I've always been convinced  was
and still am
you can't do anything without learning something like that and going
through a certain training  ft benefit from the experiences of others
so I was definitely
not someone who overestimated themselves when
you study the studies that was
always clear economics so you then
somehow did something in Switzerland in
Austria no in Austria yes in
Salzburg near Salzburg  and then
also, um, this program is owned
by Anita Elbers, which I think I
go through, where for well-deserved
sports stars, in a nutshell, again
, I can do that, I can only
recommend it in bristles, it’s good
to get to know Harald in Harvard, especially once in
a while  it has such a
very special aura I can
still remember that I came in there
you were that is
really comparable to Bayern Munich if you come
here to Bayern Munich then you are
immediately two or three levels higher you are
charged with adrenaline and you have it  the
feeling oh I have to perform fully here
exactly the same owner also yes because
there is also such a myth
with
Anita albersi simply brings
sportsmedia entertainment means
this um short degree or something
like that short degree then the
whole American, the whole
American people from sports from
the media from entertainment meets okay
okay there you do certain things
then you do certain cases that you  just
go through it, interestingly enough, we had
Paris Saint-Germain
at the time, so the development of Paris Sascha,
who then became clever,
that is then discussed with people
from different worlds
and then also top athletes from
basketball, then from entertainment
many people and what happens next  so in
terms of discussion about it, it's
great and you can of course see
the differences in marketing
in sports now in the USA or how it's
still going on here in Europe, a
simple example
in the USA  You have now, it's
been a while since I was there, you
understand  ch yes the pros or the
professional athletes
not as testimonials yes i do
my sport and on the side do a few
advertising contracts but they
already understood themselves as entrepreneurs
they already thought entrepreneurially
back then they already thought in categories
how can I also during my
time  as a professional in which
companies do I get involved in these
companies his completely different approach we
were still in Europe at the time where everyone
where that was just the norm well when I'm
an athlete I also do
a few advertising contracts and
one-dimensional thinking prevailed with us
the Americans were already on a completely different level in the
marketing of their superstars
and Stanford also did
that, so another course yes
Stanford song course that
really went against there was such a mixture
of online and online and presence
it really went on for over a year,
yes, it just happened to me dama  It was also
fun to push entrepreneurial things
forward and at the same time
just keep going.
Now somehow the business language if
somehow free cash flow contribution margin
and something like
that started here at FC Bayern
2020 in January some were irritated and
thought oh come on now  the
old goalkeeper and straddling here through the
through the office is through or
whatever he what the
expectations were and of course I've been
in the business
company for over a decade now. my
experience has of course
been completely different to me  speak
habitually without me noticing that without
me noticing it
here but everyone noticed it right away yes
and that then led to a bit
one speaks of cognitive
dissonance that means the
expectations of the people
were still Oliver  Kahn as a
goalkeeper, which I can understand, is
also okay  yes Oliver Kahn as a
goalkeeper is coming back to FC
Bayern and somehow I wasn't somewhere
completely different somehow developed somewhere
completely different
and it was difficult that was difficult
at the beginning and I actually had to look
for a
I don't think I've been active in operational football for decades now, I
actually only got used to things a little bit at a club again
these ten years, you say, you somehow
founded companies, which was the one
or two successful the philosophy I had at some point
why should I step away from my
core business now why should I
found companies now or get involved in ten
things that are now
foreign to football I don't think I wanted to
do that because I
simply have competence that's
why
we founded fenorakel AG back then where  we have built
a platform a
digital platform where people have their
opinions  could give on all topics
that existed in football in sport
we then generated this opinion
they then prepared it for the
people also in an
entertaining way it is
boring if you just say yes 10%
have the opinion 12%  the opinion
that means that
different forms of content were also
generated from it that was then fanorakel AG
then after that goldplay
goldplay
which mainly dealt with the subject of
goalkeepers that means
Training Academy set up for goalkeepers
worldwide
digital programs for goalkeeper
training and  Training develops
yes and such topics that means
it was very it was
always very close I have always stayed very close to
football and aktieninve
yes there was of course
always the opportunity for
me to get involved, let me just say it now
So
I didn't want to only invest in other companies because ic  h
decided relatively early on why should
I invest somewhere with five, eight or ten
or twelve percent and
then I have to trust the people who do
the business there,
above all
I'll say it with the knowledge that especially
in the startup area they
The probability that the whole thing will be
successful is very very low, we
know that everyone is very, very
low, so
at least I did
n’t really want to throw my money out the window, but
if I said so, then I would go to my own
company where I also have one
play a certain role, so there were
countless possibilities and offers, yes,
at that time when the startup world
also really grew in Germany a few years ago
and countless possibilities emerged,
yes, but also in Forster Capitals you did
everything,
no, because I  i just
want to not rely on others too much because of
course there was  there were
always people who gave me specific
advice but
they could give me advice
that I then thought about afterwards
but they couldn't take my money
and invest somewhere because as I
've experienced things over the course of my
two decades as a professional footballer
what's all there was the builder models
were before my time that can be
something similar but there
was again and again and again throughout the time
with the most obscure characters that
then appeared and
told you whatever, the blue
sky sent down the sky  have told and
experiences have not been good that's
why I always wanted to be master of
my finances at all times in
general it was the time when you also
things like you think afterwards I
know rightly that there is a
rumor that you had an offer
everything
Clemens is always happy about becoming a
manager at Schalke  r deed and it also shows how
fast or this urge you
have after such a long career as
an active player and then as I said yes
this break I took scarce
yes and then the urge grows
again oh now I have to be quick
now I have to go
back to the football business quickly and
then the offer came
from FC Schalke to become a sports manager or
manager and we then
met
Tennis and I thought about it days
beforehand okay how can
the strategy look like then of course I
developed the greatest Powerpoints
and then I
thought about it and
then I went to the hotel in
Rheda-Wiedenbrück and everything was very
secret then  down at the bar but still
two hours until the meeting
and you know n-tv ne then
watched NTV and downstairs there is always s  o a
ticker where the courses or
whatever is and then suddenly there was
Oliver Kahn in Rheda Wiedenbrück
and then I just
thought about whether that might really be
the right decision
, but the meeting then
took place very  good entertainment
but at some point I thought
hey
you can't do that you but you
just don't have the
necessary experience you know your way
around football but you don't have the necessary experience and that
actually encouraged me then  first of
all to do something completely different you have always been in contact with
Bayern so Uli Hoene is or can be
so the contact was always the
contact because
interestingly enough it's always there but that's
the
philosophy of FC Bayern it  there's
always this, um, this family thing that
's being talked about and it's
actually like that and it's also about
Generation to generation yes
lived on yes I also notice that
if Stefan Effenberg is there or
Bastian Schweinsteiger
comes by yes at the game they are immediately
always very cordial um so very cordial
integrated and you could here even if
you are here now  has no contract or
whatever or former player
you can always come by the
west affected poor reccomend can talk to
the people and that’s why
my contact has never been broken off
you have to say one more thing yes you
see I think I misunderstood I
appreciate this club  enormously Schalke
04 is also a big, a big
traditional club,
but you have to be very careful when you’ve had a career
over 20
years now, like in my position
or other players too,
that you have to be very careful about what you’ve
built up there  you can then
immediately destroy yourself with a wrong decision
create before you're about to become a
trainer or  I'm a manager somewhere and
it doesn't work,
then
you basically formulated the picture a bit exaggerated
, but you basically
almost destroyed everything you
've built up here over many years as an active
player, so
this decision is yes, if I become a
coach  want how do I build this
coaching career or if I want to
go into management yes how do I
also build this career as a manager in
football that has to be very well
thought out and every hasty
step could damage a lot
but coaching was an option for you
Interestingly, that was never more interesting for you,
I've always said I
've done it for 20 years in
this insane business with all that,
with all the demands, with everything that
's asked of you and now
I don't want to do it again as a
coach, no  I just wanted
a few others just
go to another level I got it off
Followed from a distance of course as a fan and
more interested and you
can tell how you thought about your brand
a bit, what
does Oliver Kahn do and with all the
decisions I've always been
surprised that you also did a lot with
Tipico because that was you
you are a risk is a gamble and
you were very present and you are still very much present and
I think you are still a testimonial
at least because it was a long relationship
from a partnership side yes that
is of course a big topic and it
has always been a big one for me
is totally present so that yes that means
if I also see myself as a brand then of
course I have to think about
which partners fit somewhere  to
me yes from the
from the from the feed from the fit yes
and Tipico yes right I worked with them for a
very long time by the way
d  he partnership with which I have
worked
the longest of all is the vieht between the Tipico brand and
how Tipico saw itself in the
business that they did and
the fit I had was also optimal, yes
, it just fitted, they just got along
just as
similar to me also with these
characteristics yes a bit
aggressive also in the market but very
very close to football very original in terms of
the brand great and Tipico has
also become super super successful
over the years on the
other side  Yes, that's right, of
course, it was about the topic of
gambling, which you can certainly
also look at very critically
The subject of the game is looking for that
's what it's about,
that you can also protect yourself or that people
can protect themselves that they
eb  en that doesn’t happen only in the
end when you have this discussion
about partners it’s always very
difficult because where should you start and
where should you stop can I
advertise sweets then the topic of sugar
yes I can now as you said
advertising for sports becomes provider
on the subject of gambling addiction, yes, I can advertise for
sustainability,
so this discussion can
then be carried on ad infinitum,
and for me it is always important that the
partner I have worked
with is aware of this topic
and also tries in these
areas, I just said it
now also doing things in the area of ​​gambling
addiction what kind of big
partnerships were there actually because you
say that was the longest the Tipico just
now I should have been from the Brent yes
let’s also say the luxury brands
probably suitable for Bavaria to
your career what was the
Luxury brands
I then worked a lot with Samsung with
Samsung yes auc  h a
great partnership where we
there we also have the topic for the first time
now purely testimonial and I am
now the advertising character
understood in a completely different way and then we really
also created content we
created a format at that time uh
you could do that on Samsung  TV, then there
was the Gold play app that you could also watch
on Samsung TVs
and
we simply recapitulated this format every Bundesliga matchday
and discussed
invited one or the other guest, which
means this partnership was very
much geared towards them  on the really
on the production of content and
less yes yes there is now the
testimonial and price now any
price now any product that was
a very, very exciting and and and and
good partnership but I
can still remember my early days
also with Burger
King we have yes I have I have
interesting I say in  interesting
things done
there were so many partnerships with
nestley i once worked together
and and so countless but
important with all of them was always i had to have
the feeling i do
n't have to bend my back here or i have to change my mind
here no idea
yes the feeling it fits  not
100% to me, I used to work
with Weight
Watchers,
but then I was fascinated by this
Weight Watchers system, how
to do it with the points and so on,
I tried it out myself and
it worked for me
and that's
just believable it's
just like that when you end your career you
just take it is like that maybe
not for everyone but for me it was like that
and um yeah then I tried this system
it worked and
somehow we came together
as partners so what can I say
bottom line it just has to you have to
have the feeling it must be right
now at FC Bayern also with Einhell
if we at Bayern and Partner also with
Einhell where I also
appear, so to speak, in the uh in the
commercial I also think that
fits very well what makes you a
is the is the largest manufacturer of
battery-operated tools okay so that
's pure afterwards pure sustainability
and gardening and you shouldn't
believe it no but I love that wonderful
that's okay for me it's one of the
best ways to switch off aside from golf
if I even ask
hard sometimes I look for the time
then I go here a bit earlier
so I'm going home now my
garden and do something I have no idea
what but it relaxes me so that
means and for that you will come along as a person
because the partners are exactly
me  if that's
something where they have nothing to do with me do
n't have to find any identification then
I can't do it but yours
Your companies are still there,
you still exist,
but they are now operated by others,
yes, of course, it’s not that
easy  the academy is
still there but that stands and falls of
course right at the beginning
these companies naturally fall with me yes
and that's why it's not such an
easy thing to say yes okay guys I
'm gone
for now because it's not at all  it's now more possible
for me to remain managing director
of my company because
when you're on the board at FC
Bayern up to the board, everything else is
no longer what's right and
good because you're supposed to
concentrate 100 percent on this job here, one thing  other things are
no longer possible how much how many
people have worked in a tip,
i.e. with gold  play or because
yes we are very fast and very we
didn't really establish ourselves in the
niche and we
also grew very quickly I had
up to 40 up to 40 employees at the top I think
thanks and then FC Bayern came along
how did FC Bayern
come about so how did that go? did they then call me somehow sarcastically
or can it be absolutely simple
callee comma over or
how's something like that
somehow been
in conversation then also
said to Ulli at some point you watch out
Ulli
if you plan at some point  that I
should play a role here
please
tell me please tell me early
because it wasn't like that for me anymore,
he only knows if you
've built up the company up to here,
managing director, you
have employees you have to take care of,
ey there  Don't you just
say more at some point, by the way,
I'm going to FC Bayern now, that was
n't an easy one for me  Question, of
course, which is clear to me if FC
Bayern offers that, you just have to
do it, yes, it is, I
almost felt an obligation
for what the club
gave me, I almost
felt an obligation in the club too
also something to give back yes
accepting this challenge according to Uli
Hoene is according to Karl-Heinz Rummenigge um
yes someone has to do it definitely
not an easy task one has
to do it that was just me then
yes and but at some point it will be
difficult yes if a company is yours
has a certain size and everything continues to
grow and develop,
everything for me was the question
up to what point can I
still do it, can I still do it
exactly and then it came at some point and then
there was somehow an evening
then  at the Tegernsee sat somehow or where
you say there were already several there
were already several so
thought about it for a certain time  enken again or
do you have several conversations in which of course we
first talked about it okay
how do you imagine it like job
how do I imagine it it was
like that
I came in 2020 Karl-Heinz
Rummenigge was still there  also that the
CEO is the chairman of the board, I
then said it might be a good thing if
I don’t come to FC Bayern straight away
and then say hello, I’m
the new CEO here, but come and first
look over the shoulder with Karl-Heinz,
now it’s going to be okay
Get to know the company get to know myself so I can also familiarize myself bit by bit
that was your idea that was your
wish that was absolutely uh that was
absolutely my wish it was actually
planned for two years yes briskly two to be on the
board but not yet
chairman and that  was that
the case after a year and a half
was
yes that Karl-heinz then just
said at some point I think Oliver is
now is too w
and
it made
sense to take on more responsibility little by little, but
Karl-
heinz then made the decision for himself to
stop half a year earlier
and so they are the third after eng  talk to
you a lot
mean now with Karl means
yes of course there are always
moments when you are with Uli anyway Uli
is always there Ulli is there at every
game that means there are so many
opportunities to talk to each other
Karl-heinz I have now  met recently
at the UEFA ECA
we then talked a lot about a
wide variety of topics that
's important yes I think that with certain questions you can of
course also fall back on
the huge experience of Uli
or Karl-Heinz on the other hand  you of
course do your own thing you
have to develop your own style
you also have to make yourself independent ah u  And
that's certainly the case with such icons
, yes, Ulli is still on the
supervisory board, or Karl-heinz, who
has been chairman of the board here for over 20 years,
but then to advertise such icons,
there are certainly
there are certainly easier things than
that so that you then  really
come alone and that's okay then I'll come
here now or is it a bit like
today with tears that you then also
bring a certain staff or environment of people with you I've noticed
is I think two people from your
environment from the ten years  of
entrepreneurship that you
got to know there that you also at least
somehow with yes at the beginning at the beginning
not when I came I did
n’t want that either I did
n’t want five assistants and three
people to bring something in my environment here
but I wanted  first get
to know the club get to know the people get to
know the association
really immerse yourself in the company mi  ch
develop first, first of
all, look at what is actually necessary, what
do I need
for the job of the
CEO, yes, what kind of
people are doing,
I can hardly know beforehand, and only
then do I have the structure bit by bit
built the way it is today
and the one in which I, er, yes, in which I
can work optimally, or you brought in a
few people who you like,
it's also somehow logical that you then
bring people with you who you know, who you
appreciate, whether it has been  who can't help here
, yes, a few people can't, I
then
brought my former partner with
me, with whom I also did a lot of business
together,
because I know him very well, I know my
strengths and weaknesses and I
don't
think it's particularly unusual that  I
need someone who can have my back in certain
situations
, who can take over certain topics for
me j  a because you
shouldn't forget that here they are yes here
there is sport and its
day-to-day requirements Hassan is
the sports manager that means on the one hand
you have to see that they are successful in sport
yes on the other
hand you also have to  part
leading the economic part the entrepreneurial part of FC Bayern Munich somewhere and
bringing it up like that and getting these two things
together that is quite a
Herculean also a company with a
turnover of over 600 million euros as many
employees meanwhile at Bayern
about 1000 employees 6  I have to bring 700
million euros in sales from sport and
business
together, and then there’s the
whole sport policy, yes, that means being on
the committees now at DFL DFB
at the ECA of the European Club
Association at UEFA all that is
also part of my job  and that
's very complex, yes, and that you
have to be relieved here and there and tea below  m
needs around you so I don't know that goes without saying
and then
there's a term that was
associated with starting here the
head program so you have an
agenda that means
you could read what's hiding
so it's that was for  me the biggest
thing so if you tell me what surprised you the
most I have to say
that he has a program
that was actually something every CEO
does the first thing he does is the topic of
strategy yes I think it is the
basic task of
a responsible person first
let's think about it okay now I
have FC Bayern Munich here for 10 years with great
success on the sporting side yes
what are the goals now where do
we want to go is there something like a
vision for this club in the
future if we set the goals  have
defined the person
want to reach here in the next three to five years how
do we want to reach them and in order
to do this how do I need some kind
of strate
to be able to achieve energy and certain goals
and for me it is a basic basic task
yes whatever has always been knitted around
it
and yes excuse me and
afterwards there is nothing
more to it than a completely normal
strategy work that starts with the fact that
you first analyze you  looks at
the company you look at the
club you try to find out where
are the strengths where are the
weaknesses you look at the environment
around the flight he what are the
dangers for chances for huge
ones coming up in the future it is
the analysis work, yes, and once you
've completed that then you can see
your keys on it, then you look
where do we have our strengths, where do we have
our weaknesses, what do we want to
focus on in the future, what will be
important here in the club and then
you start them  The strategy that we then
worked out together here in the
club is again not me
been here in the office now, so to speak,
look, I have a really great, really
great strategy, but you work that
out with the
people who make up this club here
and at some point or are we
right in the middle of it then you start
implementing it, yes and that  basically
everything was the most normal thing in the world what is
normal
what is always discussed
then yes yes and did a football club need
a strategy here I don't know so
1000 employees 6 700 million in sales
makes sense somehow so from
my point of view it does  Makes sense
to plan somewhere,
yes, and that also came, then he brought in so
many consultants, so which consultants
I think it was, overall, there was one,
I think I had one consultant in here,
everything else was people for many
years, many years too  were already at FC
Bayern and that you get
fresh blood here and there from the outside yes
where sometimes where you sometimes get fresh insides
ghts can not only swim in his
own his own soup here
yes you also need
input from outside it all became like that
it all became somehow so
much sand and a bit a
bit negative connotations the whole
thing, well, everything for me  was completely normal what
is your vision what is the goal of
the strategy something like that what kind of idea do you have
now in the end a few
words for guys always that FC Bayern
is basically a traditional club
and FC Bayern was also
great  is at FC Bayern they are
the focus, uh, you
noticed that especially with Corona
, the focus is on those who make this
club and that in our fans,
who we now
want to have all over the world, what we want to be,
we want the enthusiastic one  Being a club for
our fans isn't just in sport,
I think it's inspiring and attractive. I
think our team does it
very well or is very good at it now
h  I think if you
come to the arena learned today then you just see the
attraction you see an
attractive game but also everything else
around the club
back in my time yes bayern munich
has always seen itself as a pioneer
bayern munich
always wanted to lead the way it doesn’t matter if
we do a ver bookkeeping in do
events for our sponsors our
sponsors are big big fans yes
then that always has to yes that has to
always have an emotion I have to be
attractive it always has to be
inspiring and that's that,
yes, that's what we're committed to
and that's
why we compete here every day, of
course, sporting success is
sporting success  is
always above everything at FC Bayern and he
always defines himself here through titles yes
that is one thing but one  The cup is
first of all, yes, you are happy about it, but
the combination of sporting success
and inspiring your fans to
emotionalize
you,
to give you a home, to give you a
feeling of belonging, that
is what drives us all and that
together  I
don't think there's
anything nicer than starting to work somewhere in the morning
saying hey
everything we do here is
so good for us fans but when they're happy when they're
having a good time when they're having
fun when you  have taken their club
to their hearts if they
love their club then we have
done everything right here but believe that
is that is what drives us here what
drives us here then sorry
commitment then we have defined different fields
where we have to believe there  we
in the future we are particularly good
and we want to become even
stronger yes and the whole thing is
hidden behind the mystery
behind  the mystery uh do
you think that you can
remain successful in Europe in the long term, especially with FC Bayern
always have a
look and what money is
flowing to other clubs isn’t that
also a topic that is somehow
discussed,
yes, of course, and  we only did
that when we were just discussing that's
why we did all of it, yes, you
then realize relatively quickly the
lead that others have,
for example the Premier League,
like in Germany, has received around 1.3
billion in TV revenue  Premier
League now has four
I don't need to name a factor because those who
are ahead of us in the Premier League
are actually all clubs.
FC Bayern is not an
investor club. Thank God FC Bayern is
a traditional club and
we don't have 50 + 1 yes at  we
have 70 + 1 and we
even have that firmly anchored in the statutes
That means we
can sell a maximum of 30 percent of our
shares to strategic
investors. We've
already done some of this to adidas Audi and
Allianz. That means we're already there
. We're a bit
limited
cautiously I
put it cautiously, yes, as
far as that is concerned, other
clubs also have other options through
investors, through more television names and
so on, and that means that we
have to act very intelligently and wisely in our areas that we have to act
very intelligently and wisely on the transfer market
in the area of
sponsorship we have
to continue to be very strong together with
our partners we are in Europe too
no one fools us we have very
strong partners have very strong
partnerships at FC Bayern Munich
yes mine and you shouldn’t
underestimate that yes we  have a strong
culture a strong yes club culture that
has been going on for decades  has been built
over big stars from the 70s
over Beckenbauer
Meyers Rummenigge yes Lothar Matthias so
many stars here yes this winner brought
this mentality to the
club you shouldn’t
underestimate this mentality it’s
up to me that FC Bayern has to  also
always being lived
on being passed on to the next
generation by the generations other clubs
may have more money and
investors
but they also have this winning
mentality of FC Bayern they
don’t have it because you can’t
buy it yes and that too  is a
competitive advantage that we
can and will continue to use
and if you look at all of this now
, FC Bayern
has always outperformed in recent years in terms of
sporting success
because the others have more
financial means to  Disposition like
FC Bayern but FC Bayern was one of the
most successful clubs in the last
So for a decade FC Bayern had
always outperformed in comparison,
yes, and we believe
that that will also be possible in the future
, but I mean when you see
that even in the Premier League
the investors are now saying I
prefer it  out so currently standing yes
when we speak I think Liverpool
and Manchester United are for sale for
several billion each and there is
even concern that even there meanwhile
big US investors can no longer keep
up because maybe in the
future there will only be
Arab states then the clubs
operate as a hobby and at the same time
simply treat yourself to the image
for your fun and since so much
money just flows in that even
seasoned American professors, so to speak,
get scared and say okay then
better get it out because then you
really don’t give your head a [ __ ] where
to go  we in there at some point too
big and that's exactly why I have  Yes,
at some point the position in the ECA was
taken over in the European
association
because it was clear to me that exactly these
developments would come and that
's right, that's right, yes,
it's right
American investors are in the
process of selling shares in their
clubs  in the Premier League
and Arab investors are pushing very
hard, like for example at
Newcastle, they are now pushing very
hard into the market,
so it’s important for me to communicate very clearly with the ECA
, yes, and that
’s the line that the
others take  German clubs that now have
Borussia Dortmund or Leipzig
Leverkusen, the other clubs in
Germany, this is the subject of
financial system
financial fair play, that was
a toothless tiger
and we have all seen
how many clubs have simply made
tens of millions in losses
100 million 150 million  200
millionth don't name names of the
clubs each ka  nn think
we made huge losses without having any consequences we were
also profitable during the corona period during the corona period
we are more profitable we
are clever that means we made a
profit that was
certainly anything but easy
during the corona period while other clubs
Making a loss of 200 million and that now has no
consequences in the context of financial
fair play and that is why yes, um,
we are of course now advocating that Finnish
fair play would be replaced by the financial
systemability regulations at the moment
sounds good
yes, but here it will now be about
that really  is enforced
yes that means
I don't want to go into the details now it
should really go
beyond the scope only there is it is about that
is also enforced yes if a
club violates these
regulations then the sanctions must
also be enforced and you must
too  have a certain power and
that if that  because it really
works yes I have a certain
hope if that works then of
course it's certainly anything but wrong for us for Bayern Munich
doesn't feel a little bit in
the same boat as the
florentino perverse boss Real
Madrid  e.g. he is also the biggest in his market, so to speak
, he
also looks at the premiere and thinks,
Mister, will I be left behind now, my
colleagues in Turin are so strong because
Juventus see that, I
think they say that the Premier is
hanging  us and then he was their
solution, we build a super league
and somehow get everyone on the platform
and then not be left behind because
if everyone is acting on the same platform
, the English and the
Spaniards and afterwards and Bayern,
logically, he would actually
fit in too  that they say for you too, well
, at least theoretically,
a super would make sense dami  t the
distance is too narrow
so that you are on the same platform
as them but you are still against it
because the content of the Super League as it
was proposed at the time was
simply a catastrophe,
yes, you really had the feeling that
it went with you  Football and its origin
and its identity as we all
love nothing more to do that means if
there is a performance principle somewhere
and the qualification I have to
qualify for a competition
if all of that is no longer there somewhere
I think then it will  Football
yes then football will be
compensated somewhere that means this
Super League format that was
proposed at the time was
unacceptable yes and um
it was also the wrong way to
go and I think that’s a
very sensible development we’re seeing
now  from 20
24 25 new Champions League format yes,
and a lot has
happened since at di  With the new format
, the clubs were now
much more involved, also in what could
this format look like, also in
terms of the economic aspects, yes, that means
the clubs now had a lot
more say here
, that means something has developed
within UEFA,
something that is happening  the system so in the system
has developed further has
innovation in the system yes that is of
course very political and it is
anything but easy but we are
now seeing a further development of the
Champions League what do I mean by
that I just want to say that I do
n’t think much of it now  private
companies here from the outside, no matter what
regions of the world they
come from and now want to tell football
how great a
new format of all Super Leagues
can be here, but I think what it is in the
system, so within UEFA in the
European Club is sociation
getting involved and trying
to develop football and  d to continue to
develop that is the
right way in my opinion and a lot is already happening there,
especially when we
think about the
distribution of the new Champions League
funds er topic solidarity er topic
which
about sums flow to now  the other
European competitions conference
league
euroleague are there, things can be
changed and moved and
it didn't make sense to me why
any private companies
are coming from outside and think they know what
's best for football
a little bit in detail
what's supposed to be  because impression when you
I saw on Instagram that
you were in the stadium for the NFL game in Munich
and also the head of the NFL
, who is called that, he is then an incredibly powerful
man in the USA, then you met
him anyway thought that was it
a lot more commerce than
you know it in Germany, I would say
, then the flags were first put
out  I'll also be followed at the stadium
Caroline was played somehow so
sweetly with cell phone lights and
there were things that you think are possible in
German
football so I said
95% of the things we saw today
the cat in football I'll bring
before before  the start is the NFL
national anthem of the USA and also
Germany wanted
yes we also did that at the
opening game in Frankfurt when we started the
Bundesliga with Bayern in Frankfurt
then there was
during the national anthem so that’s
where I hear it sorry but there
then it stops with me so I why you have to
whistle there that will
never be clear to me but well is
another topic yes where the NFL plays
many things happened where I
thought the fans would really climb onto the roof
if you try if you
try to implement something old just one
thing i found i found impressive
and i was in the stadium and i have
I looked at everything, I let it all
sink in. I was
down on the pitch before the game,
went through the Allianz Arena a little bit
, it was this positive, incredibly
positive, positive atmosphere, yes, the
people came, the people wanted to have
fun, the people  had
had fun too yes and that was that
I found it impressive in the end German
people it wasn't that Americans would
have come because of the main
summer people who also live here somewhere in
Munich or in Germany yes of
course that also has something to do with it that
was  now for the first time and
that was something very special yes me
personally i don't know myself
that well in this American football
the spectators probably
much better than me for them it was of
course great to really see their stars then
that  was
a very, very, very, very
positive world, and more of that in the
Bundesliga  you say
that one can very happily wish that
it's not possible anyway or why not
I mean because this positivity
I felt the same way again one should
n't make the mistake here of comparing
different cultures with each other
the Americans have their
sports culture it's over
We've grown for decades, we have our sports culture
, it's also grown over decades,
and with us, um, they've got the
professional clubs, it all developed out of the
club system somewhere
, that was in America, it
's a completely different
approach  football is very important to us
it has a lot to do with culture it has it has a
lot to do with tradition but of
course
you should
n't close your eyes to innovation you shouldn't close yourself to the
fact that the younger generation today, for example,
simply have different demands when
it comes to football  Broadcasting
football to football to watch on TV
as a stadium  one visit from
which you simply expect something different than
a somewhat more
traditional audience. But you
shouldn't close your eyes off
well I want to do it again for me it's always
problematic here for me to compare America with something from
America with something from
Europe or something from Germany are
just different cultures and
everything  FC Bayern has its advantages and everything has its
disadvantages during his
tenure FC Bayern played another relevant
game, a game where it's
not just about friendship but instead plays its own
competitive game in the USA,
similar to the NFL here in
Germany, you have to listen to them
why  our fans
don't like it
and I knew it very well
you have to think about what
football fans are up to when they
watch football Saturday then Tuesday
Wednesday is suddenly the Champions League,
that means fans have to travel all
over Europe companies yeah that  is
all with that is all with finanziel  en
burdens also connected now
you have to think about it we are now doing a
Bundesliga game
against Dortmund in New York
for example it sounds
great then or at least sounds
innovative yes you just have to put yourself in the
shoes of the fans we don't want to
do any random things  the the
the people we
want to make happy the the the the just do
n't want it yes then what
kind of effort does that mean I have
to travel from from Munich
to New York I have
to take on all this effort yes I
I think the people have to work and and
and there are so many things that you
can do now, theoretically,
fans who then go to Germany to make
decisions and then they take
a break here, but we want to bring them
both together, of course we know
we have global  an unbelievable
number of fans all over the world
we have fans in all regions of the
world
anyway  Of course, we care about the
people
who come to the Allianz Arena every game
, yes, who accompany FC Bayern everywhere
, yes, and you
just have to listen to them and then you
have to understand them, hey, now we do
n’t just have to travel across Europe, yes
Bundesliga  We also have away games now,
we still have to
go to New York to
watch the Bundesliga game there and then
you just have to factor that into the
equation and that’s why I
understand that these things are
viewed critically and that we are
challenged  also to listen and then
to make decisions I
think but look it's the same in every
other industry yes in football
one speaks of fans not of customers
yes in other industries one speaks
of customers yes you have
to listen to your customers yes um
to offer you something about it that's
totally irrelevant but it's the
customer so you think that sometimes
i have  I have the feeling in football in general, it's
the same with the ultra scene that
maybe a certain minority
can be heard very strongly and then
creates an opinion about it that a
majority of mine might even
overlap, because the majority
tends to be silent and think that's okay somewhere
which I don't say much at all and
that one then tends to
follow decisions very strongly in
minorities, at least
that's what I thought, but I find a regulation
a regulation no matter where in which industry it's
always not bad, yes, I have to keep myself
busy, I'm
responsible for it
as CEO that we are
economically successful that
we ideally win every title every
year I have to make sure that I maximize
FC Bayern's financial resources
only on the other hand
football has a different
meaning for people yes and so  this I
say in quotation marks Re  gulative, which keeps reminding you of
certain
things, I
don't think it's that wrong at all, and I think this
conflict and this friction that
also arises is good
and I think it's important, only one thing I
've noticed in the last few
years  we have to be really careful now,
I've already
mentioned it in the course of the
current or in the course of the current
World Cup, this
politicization,
that is, this politicization that is
taking place in football, is becoming
more and more extreme and growing, and
you are overwhelmed with it
the players and I think
football is slowly being overwhelmed,
so football can
no longer do
all the things that are being pushed at it from outside, of
course you have to
deal with human rights in
Qatar, of course you have to
deal
with the role played by FIFA  takes that
are all important things yes of course  Of course
, athletes should set an example from time to time,
that's what our players do, too,
with one or the other action
outside of the field,
and football can be a piece of the mosaic
if it sets an example, yes, but
football cannot take on tasks
and football  cannot take on the role
that others actually have to
take on,
yes, to change things and I
think politics is actually
responsible for that and I think
we have to be careful that we do
n't overwhelm football,
but that we end
up overburdening it  leave it where it belongs what
should it be what should it be it should
lead to emotions it should connect it
should be fun it should
generate excitement that's the task of
football and I have to honestly say
I'm worried at the moment
whether  that everything is not a bit too
much at the moment probably know your prognosis for
the much discussed too
always annoying for you that Qatar
Airways is yes your partner will go
on do you believe or that the
feeling that now ends because of all the
circumstances that you said we will let it be
now or is
teaspoon yes we have always said
that we will have the
world championship first
then we'll sit down with our
partner with Kata Airways we
'll
talk about the partnership and
then we'll make a decision.
Personally, it
's very important to me
that we work with our partner or
with Kata Airways, yes, certain
projects too  does certain things
does where we work
together for certain for certain
development, like we did
with our women's team
, for example, who also traveled to Qatar
, who then
played football with other women's teams,
that means setting up a project for her,
yes, where we simply  a theme  occupy a place
that we then want to be able to measure ourselves against or whose
development we
want to be able to measure ourselves in. That's
important to me personally, so to make a
long story shore that we simply have
an impact as Bayern Munich
with an engagement in Qatar, but as
I said  that's all pie in the sky now
and we'll deal
with it intensively after the soccer World Cup
. Intermediate question
about the team you're with in the final, you know,
then probably
worse than today's
landscape
between never based on the talent
from a few games we had back then
had am no we developed a great
mentality but Michael
Ballack of course had everything there
as an
outstanding player and apart from that
we developed a great mentality so
at some point we convinced
ourselves nobody could and
slimy win every game
1-0 we really had it  a great great
winning mentality in the  We were more convinced
to play in this team and from the game
and I still remember
how you said back then it will be
hustle and bustle so if they don't
even survive the group phase and we
can say goodbye to it all at once
instead of my final and by the way it was also
then  it's difficult with the enthusiasm at the
beginning that's the way it is in
Germany it's always been like that in
Germany
at the beginning there's always a bit of skepticism
let's see what they're doing and then the longer the
World Cup lasts the
more you can see in the Spanish
game again yes the more  more then
the people come out of themselves and
then start to develop enthusiasm
that was always the case at the
World Cup and also at
our own in Germany it was
of course
extremely positive right from the start we want to
talk about something else, namely digital topics
I saw you're also seeing
Tim Cook, the head of Apple
recently at I  nstagram photo saw how he
visited you
oh great that was a great moment for
me too it was always
great to get to know such a capacity it was great how come something like
that so Apple called the person who
is here do you know you want to or
yes he was at the
Oktoberfest  the Oktoberfest and was just
interested in Bayern Munich at some point
wanted to see what we were doing
technologically, that means
we then imagined the campus within a
campus, yes we also
said to him that we would work on it
at some point with data that we determine
of young players and even you can
perhaps predict how it
will develop has a
lot to do with artificial intelligence
and and I don't want to get into it too deeply
that of
course interested him
and also fascinated him what kind of a game he
is  Soccer fan, so soccer, or was it
more of a bit like that, I
couldn't really
tell  he he was just fascinating was
also how incredibly
pleasant and calm
he was and we had a really
friendly word for everyone as he
listened to everything it was really
really impressive you have to say there is
the dish that Apple really
wants to buy Manu now  because of all the
Arab investors there is
really this now that is also
recorded that somehow
suddenly Apple is somehow acting the
potential buyer of such an association
that I can honestly say now
I have a hard time imagining
that Apple of course also be there  The search
is for interesting content
Content as we always
say,
yes, I can
imagine that,
but why should
n’t Apple be interested in a league, for example,
yes, why shouldn’t Apple be able to get the
rights from the Bundesliga, for example
, or  of whatever
so there they are already predestined for
we see that  yes right now how many
how many other streaming service
providers are buying rights Amazon
Prime has now bought Champions League
rights
and and and Magenta TV
is also broadcasting the football world cup right now,
so you can see
maybe Netflix will
eventually also be Netflix at some point
football rights  Interested
Yes, you can see that there are exciting
developments going on, but you believe
that the rights to the Bundesliga are
worth more than they were last time
, that's not so easy now,
there is a tendency to see more bidders,
but the
willingness to pay is
already felt  a little less so I
said Sky Germany is even for
sale uh if you hear it like that they wo
n't be able to offer that much now the
son doesn't earn any money with the
rights
either so you don't really see who is supposed to pay for the really big packages right now,
yes I do  believe that we I'll say that
the big growth yes v  especially when it comes to
the Bundesliga international
international if we all
know we are not
satisfied with the international
marketing of the Bundesliga
here too so that you can
maybe make it more effective or
understand
the international rights of the Premier
League  yes, not the national rights in
England, but the international
rights, which are sold all over the
world so that I can see the Premier League
all over the world,
these are now higher
than the national rights, i.e. 2.1
billion compared to 2 billion,
and we have this ratio
About
a billion nationally and probably
200 million want
internationally and that's where you can see the
potential that the Bundesliga
has internationally and the
Bundesliga is a highly
attractive product also in an
international context, we also
have
top stars in the
Bundesliga  we have de  n the
highest average attendance of all
are we have top stadiums top
infrastructure yes the Bundesliga
is one of the most balanced are the
Bayern
[Laughter]
what can I say again
the potential is mainly
international and there are many
efforts underway right now  also at
the DFL and the fact that we are getting better there
and that we are also taking paths that
we have not taken in the past
is not frustrating for you today
if you do your job well
if FC Bayern wins a shame
actually the Bundesliga can  you
don't say that or say
something, I've heard it too
[laughter]
yes, it's not that we do
n't have an interest in tightening this
competition as much as
possible. Bundesliga football, but you
can't do that in FC Bayern
Of course that
's the way it is and we have each other
or we are very
open when it comes to discussions  Of course it's all fine,
precarious topics yes, but nonetheless
that doesn't mean that we're going to do it,
that we want to do it, but you
shouldn't close yourself off to discussion now,
just openly discuss what
's best for the Bundesliga
, but that will also
happen  but it's also done, but if
the others are just surprisingly
bad, you have to say well
, I wouldn't
say that, I can't judge
that from a distance now
how the others are managed
only here at FC  Bavaria here, too, many correct and good decisions were
made in the past years or even
decades
, yes, there are
also cities in Germany that may
even have a stronger
economic power than Munich, I
come from a Hamburg area, yes, but for
example he is certainly where too  there would be a
lot of potential FC
Bayern has just I like it  Goodbye
said, FC Bayern made a lot of right decisions in the last few decades,
if you take a closer
look, it's characterized by an
incredible continuity.
Continuity in the leadership with Uli Hoene
has been with Karl-Heinz Rummenigge for many,
many years
and you can have this continuity by the way
Also in clubs, they are
also very successful, like
SC Freiburg, for example, which shows that
you can achieve a lot with less
, also continuity in
management Continuity in leadership
also with the coach
I mean how long has it been
Streiche is already a coach
from SC Freiburg, so there are also
reasons why
clubs are more or less
successful. You're
thinking about the future
his, who also played at the highest level at
Bayern and according to the
philosophy, um  there aren't
that many anymore, at least those who immediately
come to mind are
Germans, but do you have a Philipp
Lahm that might be an issue again one day,
or who
could that be from the current team
? again, it's the philosophy  of the
club also the chairman of the board, in the
best case that the
chairman of the board comes from football
, among other things, because
if FC Bayern is
convinced that it's all about
football and that's why it's the
same here, we'll see in  Ajax, we
are also the only two clubs that
still have former players as
CEOs and it's
not like this football business is
somehow just declining
, on the contrary, it's
constantly progressing, FC Bayern
meanwhile has 1000 employees, everything is becoming
more complex  everything is becoming
more demanding you have to act on many
levels and that's for
you, uh  m yes for a former
soccer player as a yes a
special challenge to prepare for such
a position in the future yes
and to do it
woah so
could Thomas
Müller you would have to ask
them yourself if they even want that yes
me  I'm also in contact a lot with Bastian, with
Bastian Schweinsteiger
and also in contact with Michael Ballack
and mine with the guys I
used to play with
and it's not that they
're all particularly unhappy
with their lives, so I'm taking
on this challenge
you have to want that too, yes, and many
do entrepreneurial things too, yes,
which I think is very good, which is also a
lot of fun for them, which also brings them a lot of
satisfaction, and
I can well imagine that you can really imagine that
consider whether you take on this
challenge Bayern Munich in the
main
responsibility
whether you accept this responsibility  who
actually makes their social channels
who actually makes it
quite big on Instagram with somehow
lost a million because LinkedIn also has 100,000
followers too or
I already have 120,000 but that was also
important to me again um I think of
course I had to
deal with it very carefully how did I do it
before how did I do it
when I wasn’t at FC
Bayern yet, of course you can do it a
bit differently as the
CEO you have to think it over
carefully you can
now do this
continue to push very easy things out,
I then made a post with
this famous picture of me with this
leg stretched out there in Dortmund and so on
and lo and behold the Chancellor's
CEO, again,
people think it's cool and that
bothers me  nobody really bothers the scene
recently in the
Westfalenstadion on which the tri  stage then set it up
, that honestly surprised me a bit
that it was so high
because football has always
been so emotional for me, I didn’t feel like myself there at all,
so there
were other moments,
yes, but I believe that  it's just
part of this business and
it always sounds like that CEO of
course it's a very
responsible position but
we do football and football
is still entertainment yes
and you have to have that in the
back of your head somewhere actually came to  the
caster because above all that they found out through
PSG that they would always win the Champions
League
yes this year it would be the logical
consequence of everything
they have done but they have not yet
won it
yes now again a line  corresponds
to doing the calculation that
was really worth it
I think that we won all the games in the
group phase h
But then I had
a few thoughts
no, but of course it's an
iron 50/50 game, I think both
teams are outstanding
individually and they play
outstanding football, but you have to see
now, the big
challenge will be the team going
back there after the World Cup
bring where they were before the World Cup
we were in a great mood before the World Cup
won every game had a good
atmosphere in the team then
now the cat then the World Cup
has never happened there we have
terrible injuries that really
hit us all deeply really  was also
shocked by Lukas that
I had Lukas hernand that he had just
worked on it again and
now had to
fight his way through rehabilitation again for months
but that's how it is he has our
full
our full support but what can
I say about this  this this this cut
through the World Cup in the season and im in
de  In the winter months we knew beforehand
that they would say that
it was going to be special and that is why we have also
positioned ourselves as broadly as possible in terms of
karda okay okay well anyway
I now think I also have an
important role as a
representative of Germany in this
role so Bayern Munich like  often that
now always was also in the NFL
reporting now that the club
with the most World Cup players and so
that's really a word so there really
quality so Manager Germany suffers yes
but now you are suddenly required
this quality Manager Germany somehow
high worldwide  to say yes but it was
already it was actually always
like that there were always these blocks Bavaria
has always been a block in the
national team that's clear
[music]
yes it's not that it's
new or that we  suddenly
standing there and saying oh what's going
on at the World Cup and
we knew that beforehand is our own  Actually,
if you win the Champions League, then
you finally have in your contract
as before as a player and an extra bonus
that comes or something like that people
so I can’t talk about that
a huge a huge stand so talking about the contents of the
contract
are in the one with the
ECA  and as part of that I can
probably watch a game
thank you very much for your time for
the detailed answers and um let's
see what the next few years will be,
thank you very much
[music]